hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and.com and in this video I want
to demonstrate for you how to crush a
medication when you're giving it through
a tube fitting or orally so what is the
purpose of why we crush medications well
number one if a patient has a tube
feeding we need to crush the medication
into a fine powder so we can instill it
through the tube so I can get to the
stomach or the patient just has trouble
swallowing big pills they get choked on
them so we have to crush it and either
mix it in water or some type of food
like applesauce so let me demonstrate
for you how to do this through it for a
two feeding or orally and then I'm going
to follow it up with some tips of some
things you want to keep in mind whenever
you're doing this skill okay first let
me demonstrate for you how to crush a
medication to give through a tube
feeding okay first before you do this
you always want to follow your hospital
protocols and how much water you will be
giving before you give a medication in
between medications and after
medications because each Hospital has a
strict protocol and what you follow for
two feedings for a minute for medication
administration and the following
supplies you will need you will need a
pill crusher whatever you have access to
you will need a medicine cup because you
will be putting the medication in that
after you crush it into a fine powder
you'll need a 60cc syringe ntral syringe
that will connect to the patient's tube
so you can easily give the medication
and you'll need warm water per pill
about 20 cc's of warm water that you'll
mix each medication in to give and then
you'll need a pair of gloves and of
course before you do this you do hand
hygiene and always put your gloves on
whenever you're crushing medications
because you're breaking these
medications down and to where the
chemicals are and you do not want to get
these on your skin they can be dangerous
okay so you're going to get your pill
crusher make sure you have the right
medication the right patient check
everything off before you start doing
this and for this particular crusher you
just stick the medication in the bottom
and we
this on top and then we just twist it
and as we do this it starts to crush the
medication and you twist it until it
can't go anymore and then untwist it and
then just try to get that residue off at
the end so you're making sure you get
all the medicine in there I like to just
wipe it in there and then empty it into
your medicine cup you got to make sure
it doesn't stick on the sides especially
if you're using one of these kind of
twist type pressures okay then what
we're going to do is we are going to
instill some water in our medicine cup
and mix it up really good and then we'll
draw it up and just stir it because you
want everything stirred up very well so
it doesn't stick in your tube and cause
your tube to become clogged because a
clogged tube is no fun for you or the
patient and and you will crush each pill
separately you never crushed medications
together because when you crush them
together it will break down that
protective coating and those chemicals
will mix together and affect their
ability to work and it can decrease
their effectiveness and then you're just
going to draw up with your syringe
medication
and sometimes I like to settle at the
bottom so you've really got to stir it
to make sure you can get it all up in
there and I like to get the air out of
my syringe slowly push it up there put
your cap back on and then you're ready
to instill that into the tube and you'll
give that and then flush behind it and
then repeat your next medication and if
you were using a type of crusher like
this you would need to clean all the
residue off wash it with warm soap and
water before you do the next medication
because you don't want to mix medication
and that goes for if you're going to be
using this for another patient now let
me show you how to crush medicines to
give orally okay and with this what you
can do is you'll mix the medication with
either water or here we're going to use
applesauce a tip is not to use the
patient's favorite food or something on
their food tray that they're going to be
eating like green beans or something
like that because these medications when
crushed taste horrible you don't want to
ruin the patient's food so what you're
going to do is you need to get your pill
crusher you need to get some applesauce
if that's what you're going to use to
mix it in a spoon get the right peel for
the right patient and then your gloves
then of course before you do this
perform hand hygiene and put your gloves
on and put your pill and you're pill
crusher and use your pill crush or
according to how you're supposed to use
it
and again you crush pills individually
because you don't want to mix them
together because they can affect how
they work and typically what I like to
do is I you like to use one spoonful of
applesauce per pill and then just repeat
with however many pills I have because
you don't want to mix one pill and a
huge thing of applesauce because one
because if you have to give three more
pills that's a lot of applesauce that
patients going to be eating so try to
use the smallest amount of applesauce as
possible so you don't feel your patient
up so we're just going to put it in
there and be careful you get all of the
contents in there okay and remember you
will clean your pill crusher in between
medications and in between patients if
you're not using a closed system crusher
and you will mix this up try to mix it
up as good as you can so patients aren't
getting big chunks of pills in their
mouth and once you have it mixed good
administer that to the patient and then
repeat as necessary now let me give you
some quick tips to remember whenever
you're crushing medications tip number
one remember that not all medications
can be crushed and if you're ever unsure
if a medication can be crushed or not
always call pharmacy because they're
great and helping you determine if you
can crush it or not and as a nurse
whenever you work overtime you get
experience you will learn what you can
and can't crush and another thing is to
look at the medications name because a
lot of medications that will have the
name and then they'll have these letters
after the name like detrol la la stands
for long-acting you can't crush that and
there's typically five categories of
drugs that you cannot crush and they are
enteric-coated long-acting
extended-release controlled relief slash
delivery or sustained relief slash
action and to help you remember those
five categories of drugs remember this
new
onic seniors erroneously crush and tear
it coded laxatives and this will help
you to remember it because a lot of
times patients who are taking crush
medications are your seniors your
elderly patients and seniors the
abbreviation for seniors is SRS so
that's sustained-release erroneously er
is for extended release crush CR is for
controlled release and then
enteric-coated is for enteric coated and
then laxatives is for LA which is
long-acting and the last tip is to try
to consult with the physician or the
pharmacist on trying to get the
medication switch to a liquid form or an
IV form so the medication doesn't have
to be crushed and that may be possible
if your patient just doesn't like
swallowing their pills and they'd rather
have it in the liquid form but if your
patient requires like nectar thick
liquids or honey thick liquids that they
may not be a candidate but always just
try to consult with other parts of the
team to see if you can help the patient
out okay so that wraps up this
demonstration on how to crush
medications thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos